[Music]
hello everyone
and oh no oh no
happy new year happy new year i knew i
was gonna mess it up but
uh welcome back to the first lecture of
2021 hopefully you enjoyed
the new and improved countdown we'll see
if we stick with that
every week or not uh but the pawn has
dropped
has promoted to a queen it is the first
lecture of 2021 and i am happy
to be here all right i'm so happy i'm
gonna do it again since i messed up the
first one
boom happy new year everybody it's a
little smoky that's okay
all right well this of course is chess
openings explained and my name of course
is caleb denby
uh and tonight it is a fairly normal
lecture despite all the theatrics we are
going to be talking about a new opening
today
uh and that is the reverse bononi the
bononi backwards the backwards bononi
with opposite colors uh and let's take a
look at what that actually means
so of course we have the normal bononi
starting as a d4 opening
but as always when an opening is
reversed that means
that the colors have been flipped and
the player that has the white pieces
plays an opening traditionally meant for
a player with the black pieces so
here instead of seeing white play d4 and
taking over the center as you would in a
normal banoni we are going to look
at the move c4 it actually originates
from the english
so to arrive at this opening we're going
to take a look from the black side
you play knight to f6 as black white
continues in the english manner with g3
we get e6 bishop g2 and d5 so we see
black is actually the one with the
bigger central presence in the reverse
bonnoni
because black is playing the role of the
player with the white pieces
we continue now with knight f3 and
bishop e7
and castles and castles so i want to
actually pause here
as we talk about the opening for a
little bit
uh the strength of the english or one of
the many strengths of the english
as well as openings like the ready
openings uh with an early bishop g2
is that it has a lot of transpositional
opportunities and that is the case here
so tonight we're looking at the reverse
benoni from the black
side the black point of view because i
do think this is a great way to play
against the english in english type
setups
but i do want to mention that players
with the white pieces will always have
the opportunity to transpose to openings
like the catalan
with something like d4 and they can even
transpose a little bit earlier on to
normal d4 openings with something like
knight c3 and of course even d4
on move two is perfectly playable so you
have to be ready
is what i'm saying to be able to play
with this setup against a variety of
openings including
d4 here including you know other catalan
transpositions
and even an early knight c3 so
with that all in mind what we are going
to be looking at today is the
complications after the move b3
so this is the move you can expect to
see if your opponent is interested
in playing a pure english defense not
our
english opening not necessarily defense
but this is what they play if they're
not
interested in transposing to d4 lines
[Music]
so how do we get to a benoni type
position
from here well it's actually not too
difficult
all we need to do is take over these
dark squares in the center
as black and it's actually not very
difficult to achieve
you simply start with the move c5 and
now all of a sudden it becomes very very
difficult for white to maintain control
over this d4
square in fact so difficult that it may
be impossible
now it's not too late actually for white
to
transpose into some other stuff white
can still sort of
abandon the pure english plan by taking
on d5
and continuing out with a move like d4
and this is perfectly fine
for white to play as well but it's just
another one of those positions
where white is able to transpose to more
traditional
catalan type of positions now
again we're not focusing on that today
we're focusing on the reverse bononi
pure
which happens after bishop to b2 and now
black can either play d4
immediately or black can prepare with
knight c6
and i'm going to say stick with knight
c6 for the moment
because the only real downside to
playing d4 is that you do have to know a
little bit about this
weird gambit line which i didn't feel
like studying and probably you don't
feel like studying either
so starting with knight c6 is perfectly
fine now it's not too late for white to
transpose into this line we looked at
earlier
but we're not really giving white any
extra opportunities here because white
could have played c takes d5 on the
previous turn
as well so i like knight c6 instead of
d4 because it avoids this
random b4 line now though we do arrive
at our main position
after the move e3 and after e3
black is in fact taking over the center
with the move
of d4 uh and this is how we arrive
at our benoni structure white takes on
d4 pretty much all the time
and black takes back and now we are one
move
away from arriving at this structure
that you see in the normal benoni
just for comparison i'm going to flip
over to the actual benoni here
this is how we develop out stuff
like this and this is a perfectly
reasonable you know starting tabia for
the banoni
you notice these trademark pawns on e4
and d5
taking over the center this is why white
is thought to have
some advantage in some lines of the
midoni is because of this extra central
space
and you see the same central space uh in
this position here for black
with this central pawn duo now there's
one key difference
from normal benoni uh structures aside
from the fact that white of course has
an extra tempo
and that is this bishop on b2 and that's
really
going to be the focus of a lot of what
we're going to talk about tonight is
this bishop on b2
does it improve white's position or does
it actually hamper white's position
and the result of the opening is pretty
much exclusively going to depend
on whether or not this bishop turns out
to be useful on b2
or if white can make it useful in some
other way
so that's what we're going to talk about
tonight so any questions on
just what we're talking about before we
jump into the nitty-gritty here and look
at some variations
questions about what it is exactly we're
looking at
now jimmy says you thought uh white
should play cd5 and then d4
so yeah that's one of the
transpositional lines uh that that is
perfectly playable
uh whether you play bishop b2 or not
first doesn't really matter
you play cd5 and then black can actually
either take with the knight
or the pawn i think taking with the
knight is actually a bit better
but uh either is perfectly fine for for
black and you can also
do this in this position as well and
there's a ton of games here but actually
more more common by far is this line
with e3 this is sort of
the only way to play a pure english
where you're not
transposing into these d4 openings
good question though who will play like
this
who plays like this for white looks
pretty poor any proper gm's play this
well fabiano caruana anish geary vasily
ivanchuk fabiana caruana
ray robson we're going to take a look at
a game there so some some
people play this some people play this
um
but good good question uh all right
let us continue on then let us continue
on will this be similar to the normal
benoni ideas as the chess king
and yes that is uh a very good starting
point so we're going to look at typical
benoni ideas and how they take place
in this reverse benoni starting from
this position
and then we're going to see what the
differences are and we're going to see
that a lot of those differences
result from this bishop being on b2 so
without further ado let's jump into a
real game example
uh actually i light one more ado
so i played the move d3 because it gets
us to this position
where we have the central pawn duo in
the bedoni uh the fastest but white does
actually have a move order improvement
here that is quite common
and that's to play the move rook e1 now
what's the point of rookie one well the
point is
we are stopping black from achieving
this this pawn duo in the center
by taking control of this e5 square so
of course
e5 no longer a playable move for black
and there are a variety of lines that
black can choose
knight e8 rookie 8 queen b6 bishop c5
these are all playable moves all with
the idea of eventually
playing this e5 move now the line i'm
actually going to recommend
is in fact this knight e8 line but if we
have time i am going to analyze one game
in the rookie 8 variation
because the ideas are are very very
similar
so rookie won the move order nuance
first though let's take a look at a real
game between
somebody by the name of bronco dom
lia leonovich and vasily ivan chuck
and here we have knight f3 knight f6
c4 so slightly different move order but
we are arriving
quite quickly at our english positions
uh
and here actually rather than bishop g2
ivan chuck's opponent chooses to play b3
first which is also perfectly fine
now he gets not bishop e7 but first c5
so you can arrive at our position
through a variety of move orders but
basically
all the english moves knight f3 bishop
g2 are going to be played
and for black i like playing bishop b7
before c5
just because it's a little bit less
committal but doesn't make a great deal
of difference we actually see knight c6
by ivan chuck first as well
now castles now we do see bishop e7
and e3 by white rather than bishop b2
but again this doesn't change anything
after castles bishop b2 we do actually
arrive at our main position
so uh once again i'm gonna go through
these opening moves
and sort of show you the the reason why
i like this line so much for black so
there are of course a variety of ways
you can play against the english and the
ready for example
e5 is very very popular as a response to
the english
but if you're building sort of a
repertoire around playing openings like
the qgd
openings like the nimzo indian openings
like the rogozin for example as i myself
play
then it doesn't make the most sense
necessarily to be throwing in this
random line
with c4e5 it's a lot more consistent
to play in this manner with knight f6
notably even against knight f3 now your
e5 line is sort of null and void
but it's a bit more consistent to play
with knight f6 e6 and d5 and then you
get this type of structure
that you've seen before and the game can
develop from there so that's why i like
this line so much
because it starts from such a versatile
opening with knight f6 and e6
which really does allow black to go in
any number of directions
but okay let's jump into the actual
position castles bishop b2
and we do see d4 now we have e takes d4
and c takes d4 and uh ivan checks
opponent does play the nuanced move of
rook
to e1 and the line i'm recommending is
this move knight e8 that ivan chuck
chooses
here so what is going on in the position
why have we played the move knight e8
does anybody in the chat think they see
the idea
and does anybody in the chat have a
suggestion
for white in this position
so oliver says it's like a really bad
benoni though
so that's the the question is is it
actually a bad benoni because of this
bishop on b2
black skull is going to make this bishop
look stupid on b2
because it's staring at our powerful
soon-to-be central pawn duo if
everything goes correctly
but white's idea is to say white has the
extra tempo
can make use of it with ideas of
controlling e5 and can
actually on occasion make use of the
pressure against the d4 pawn
that this bishop provides so it's that
is the question
is it a bad benoni because this bishop
is on b2 or does white's extra time in
the opening
actually make a concrete difference and
that is
the the balance you have to strike in
this line
the idea is f6 e5 and that is of course
correct f5 would be a little bit early
first we have to make sure
we are controlling the dark squares but
as we'll see
f5 is going to be an eventual plan for
black in many of these positions
so now white continues out with d3
arriving
at the typical benoni structures with
f6 by black and e5 occurring on
the next move so chat room
what do you think about this move d3
does white have an improvement in this
position and this is something that you
should
hopefully be able to find using benoni
principles
that that you might be a little bit more
familiar with right
i'm sure more people know about the real
benoni rather than the reverse bononi
so is there an improvement for white
here based on principles
that you can sort of borrow from the
actual benoni
and yeah jeff has the right idea here
knight e5 is the improvement
that i'm claiming white should pretty
much just always include
now looking at the database d3 is
actually the more popular move
and uh just for for some numbers in the
lead chess database
d3 has been played 112 times 95 only 85
but i i do think 95 is just strictly the
better move and
that benoni principle i'm talking about
is this idea
that you should trade off one set of
pieces in
the bonnoni one set of minor pieces
should come off the board if you're
playing the benoni with either
either side meaning when you have less
space you want to to trade off one set
of pieces
because your pieces tend to just step on
each other's toes in the benoni
and we're going to see a little bit of
that happening in this game
but i really do think this 95 line is a
bit better
the downside is that white loses some of
that extra time
that white had gained but now white is
able to breathe a little bit more freely
without this sort of stifling knight
sitting on the f3 square
the bishop is open white has good
control of e4 and pressure
on the queen's side so we are going to
take a look at what happens with knight
e5 but first let's take a look at this
idea of
d3 so d3 and the idea now is a little
bit different
for white rather than remove this knight
on e5
in exchange for this knight on c6 we're
gonna see white try to organize all of
the forces to make use of this bishop
on b2 that's the main idea with leaving
this knight on f3
is to increase the pressure against d4
and make this bishop on
b2 useful so we are going to continue as
planned with f6
and now the the most natural way to
develop and the most sensible way to
develop
is with knight a3 as played in the game
so again the point really is we are
piling on the pressure
against this pawn onto d4
uh which is not really typical of of the
menoni
and it might seem nonsensical with
black's next to move of e5
to keep pressuring this pawn but we'll
see that there is actually some idea to
it
uh by the way here knight c2 is the most
popular move and i
suspect the most sensible move but white
chose to delay it for a few turns in
the game that uh and actually never
played knight c2 in the game
uh but uh i do want to mention
this not an a3 it is just a stepping
stone uh usually to get to the c2 square
and the idea is not just to pressure d4
but of course to support the the
queen side pawn advances as well right
it would be
a6b5 in the actual benoni in the reverse
benoni it's white trying to play a3 b4
uh to gain some queen side space so
knight c2 is the most popular
white shows a slightly different way of
developing out here with queen e2
first and this is the main idea
of the bishop on b2 it's this pressure
down the e file it may seem like a cheap
tactic
or a cheap kind of trick to make a pin
down the e file force your opponent to
lose the d-pawn
but it is actually a really important
resource for white and that's why i
wanted to highlight this game
in particular even though it's all the
way back from 1988 it really highlights
this idea in particular for white and
why it's actually not
the best and why i don't think this d3
line is necessarily the way to go
so what am i saying i'm saying white is
increasing the pressure
down the e file because white is trying
to make
this pressure against d4 meaningful the
only way to do that
is to pin this e pawn to black's
slightly uncomfortable pieces
sitting behind it on the e file so we
see queen e2
actually as a result of the bishop on b2
because we want
to pressure the e file and then
indirectly pressure the d-pawn
and in response to this ivan chuck
actually plays the move
bishop g4 which might not be the move
that would come
come to mind first uh at least for me
right
to me it seems like f5 is a great square
even e6 is a great square
but instead ivan sure goes out to g4 and
i think this is probably
to force some weaknesses by white in
order to make the plan
of attacking d4 still feasible right
with this pin here
you're not really getting any pressure
on d4 and so you're forcing a concession
by white in the form of h3 and so this
is why
we do see bishop g4 by ivan chuck and h3
by white because white is going for this
plan
of pressuring the d4 pawn and in order
to make that work we can't have this
bishop sitting on g4
uh ivan trick then retreats this bishop
back to e6 which i
would like to mention i sort of think
isn't even
the best square for the bishop at this
point i think it might make more sense
to actually drop this bishop back to h5
mainly for the purpose of maintaining
this pin
white probably can play the move g4 but
then we're quite happy to tuck this
bishop either back on g6
or more likely back on f7 where it does
a nice job of helping to defend
our king but bishop b6 in the game so we
will focus on this for the moment
and then we see white actually not come
with knight to c2
but actually knight to b5 and really
white has gone all in on this idea
of pressuring d4 pressuring down the e
file but now we'll see
that it actually just isn't all that
frightening after all
right all black has to do is defend the
d pawn with pieces
rather than the e pawn and ivan chuck
does so with the move bishop c5
it's important to understand this little
game that these players were playing
uh on the surface it looks as though
both sides are just sort of developing
out
uh you know with sort of random random
moves like queen e2
but all these moves were with the
purpose of trying to pressure the d4
pawn and this is one of the plans that
players with the white pieces have often
gone for in the position
it just so happens that it doesn't
really seem to be all that threatening
if black is able to defend this pawn
effectively
uh okay in fact ivan chuck has such a
good setup here for defending the the d4
pawn
that's uh damn dom
dominovic dominovic
decides to play the move bishop a3 which
in fact could have been done
uh some something like 10 moves ago
where when white played knight a3 bishop
a3 was already legal there
and was perhaps the the better option uh
so bishop a3 played in the game and we
do see these pieces come off the board
and what does this mean for a position
well it means white has given up a lot
of the pressure on the d4
pawn but white has also you know not
left himself
with a terrible bishop right at least
this bishop managed to trade itself off
rather than be sitting on b2 doing
nothing for the entire game
uh all right with that now we have
this middle game position without the
dark squared bishops
so white's opening sort of ploy seems to
have failed for the moment
in the form of attacking d4 and where
does that leave us
well that leaves us with just a typical
benoni
and what happens in a typical bononi
well the side with more space
tends to be better and i think that's
just going to be the case here
so the idea of this reverse benoni uh i
i
sort of want to make clear is to get
something immediate with the white
pieces you want
some sort of tactical complication some
sort of opening of the position
almost right away because if you don't
get that then you're playing a binoni
with the white pieces like what are you
doing
how are you playing the binoni with the
white pieces like
people don't play the benoni with the
black pieces anymore so to do it with
the white pieces
is is pretty bold and that that's what i
mean here
is players with the white pieces aren't
necessarily just aiming for normal
bononi as we are arriving at here
they're arriving at something sort of
immediate and if they're not getting it
then they're stuck in a benoni and as
such white should be a little bit worse
in this position but that's enough
talking let's see
the middle game plan that ivan chuck
engages here
in this typical benoni structure that
you can expect to get
from the reverse binoni he starts with
queen to d7 which is a perfectly fine
move
accuracy is is not accuracy and move
order isn't necessarily the most
important in this case
you could have very well played a move
like knight c7 but queen d7 is is
perfectly fine as well
king h2 and defending against the threat
and now we do see knight c7
and notably now this pin on the e file
isn't necessarily even working anymore
due to this knight's defense of this
bishop
we see the move knight c2 being played
and of course now
the typical stopping move on the queen
side of a5 comes into play
uh this comes a lot later than it would
in the normal bononi when
black usually threatens to play a6b5
quite early on and
white plays the move a4 to stop it but
the same idea holds true here
right typical bononi moves now knight d2
is played by white trying to open up
this bishop and perhaps highlighting
that this knight maybe should have been
traded off moves ago
for this knight on c6 by playing knight
e5 now we see bishop f5
by ivan chuck just slowly but surely
improving the pieces
i should note that black is not the side
to be in a rush in this opening
white is the one who needs to really
prove something early on
or else i'm going to say it again white
is stuck playing a benoni with the white
pieces
all right white plays the move knight e4
occupying the central square
now we see the simple move knight e6 by
ivan shook
countering this knight and defending d4
and
defending against f4 now we see a3
bishop back to g6 and b4
by white has been achieved but ivan
check was not worried because the move
f5 is the idea here and i think this is
a really
really sort of uh typical game almost
like the
the epitome of the reverse bononi games
uh as far as the plans go for both sides
white tried this early stuff early on
black managed to refute it by
defending accurately and now white is
going for this queen side space
while black is pushing in the center
these are the typical plans in the
position
uh very very similar to the actual
benoit
all right we continue now with knight d2
by white and ivan shook wastes no time
just plays the move e4 and this is the
typical break
that you should be looking for with the
black pieces in these positions you want
to play the move e4
not necessarily to immediately win the
game but
to push your central majority through
and
use that to to win the game black isn't
really looking to checkmate all that
often
in these positions black is looking to
break through in the center
and use those powerful central pawns
just to to win the game outright as ivan
chuck does here
now i don't want to spend too much time
from here on out
because we have really seen the
beginnings of the middle game plans
that are hinted at in the opening and
this is of course a class on the opening
just not on these games
so let's fast forward a little bit uh f4
is played
by white and this was sort of a
necessity otherwise knight e5
by black would sort of be ending the
game
so f4 in order to stop knight e5 and now
ivan chuck plays
h5 hinting at the break of h4 loosening
up
the f4 pawn ch4 by white to prevent that
and now ivan chuck does some funny
shuffling with the rook
first coming rook a to e8 which makes a
lot of sense with the potential opening
of the e file
but then after rook f1 the strange move
is rook b8
and i think the idea here was ivan check
was just looking to
counter white's push on the queen side
with the move of b5 but that doesn't
actually come to fruition in the game
not not a huge deal just a couple
strange rick moves by ivan chuck that
took me a while to to decipher 91
by white is now threatening to capture
on e4 i guess i should highlight the
tactic that has been in the air for
quite some time
that pawn on e4 has always been
uncapturable due to the pawn
pawn d3 fork but after knight e1 we
actually see
a different idea by ivan chuck he simply
allows
white to capture on e4 we see this with
a takes b4 d takes e4
and d3 and this is the last big point i
really wanted to touch on in this game
black is not necessarily winning
material by pushing the central pawns in
fact black may be losing
one of the central pawns with the move
e4 but the point is
the pawn itself is so so valuable on d3
it is interfering with all of white's
pieces
it is threatening to go even further and
become a queen
and this is sort of the the strong point
that gives black
some advantage after this breakthrough
of e4
so this idea of e4 you don't even
necessarily
need to have it fully fully prepared
where white can never capture it
sometimes it's enough just to get a
powerful d-pawn in
in the complications notably
this cannot be captured if you take with
the knight for example
i believe the simple move is rook a to
d8 when
there's no way to defend both of these
knights rick f3
means knight to d4 with a fork and
a similar problem occurs if you take
with the queen i believe i think now we
just trade queens first
and the same idea uh exists this time
f takes e4 is the problem uh
so d3 good move by ivan chuck and then
queen d1
we see captures captures on e4 and now
ivan chick just plays with this pawn
and in the complications we do actually
see a blunder
by white and ivan chuck goes on
to win the game i should say by the way
that
in this position ivan check has some
advantage with this pawn
sitting here nicely on d3 but then he
actually just trades it in
for an exchange uh in
this manner where black loses the bishop
white loses the rook
and after this black doesn't really have
any advantage
so it should be noted that this d3 pawn
is really really strong
but trading it in for an exchange as
seen in the game turned out to be sort
of
the wrong way to go here for ivan chuck
even still
he ended up winning the game so
questions on
this game in the the opening in early
middle game in particular there was a
lot we sort of touched on here as our
sort of introductory game to the opening
so questions here
it's even shook even shook
yvonne shook i i knew that i just ivan
chuck whatever man whatever
i'll just call him chucky i'll just call
him chucky can we go back to the opening
yeah so i sort of flew through the
latter half of that game but uh
here we are
juna says this is a horrible opening
for who i'm trying to recommend it as an
opening
for black against the english
okay how would i rate the benoni in the
reverse bononi overall
uh their chest openings i don't know
it's difficult to rate entire openings
the benoni is
sort of too big of a too big of a thing
to rate and as far as the reverse bononi
i think if white uh it comes down to
specifics again if white is able to get
something immediate
as we'll see in a couple examples in a
little bit
then it can be quite good for white but
if white is unable to get that immediate
uh you know concrete idea out of the
opening
then i do think black tends to be better
okay let us continue on the questions
are drifting from
the game in particular uh but first let
me actually recap
so this game we saw the accurate rookie
one
98 by black but then rather than trade
off these knights
we see d3 by yvonne chuck's opponent
and the point of this move is to use
this knight in this bishop
to put some early pressure on this pawn
on d4
we saw though that this idea didn't work
thanks to some accurate moves by yvonne
chuck
and after that white gives up uh trades
off these bishops on a3
and then we just have a typical bononi
style game
black hampers white's development on the
queen side and then eventually
breaks through with f5 and e4 with the
idea
of getting a powerful d3 pawn which went
on to win black the game
and that is sort of the typical way
these slower games
can go with that i want to move on
to a very interesting game between one
grand master
emilio cordova against a random 2300
by the name of liren zhao
so let's take a look from black's site
black does end up losing this game
because they were playing emilio cordova
who was a very strong grandmaster
but i think they showed some really
interesting opening ideas
and emilio i do think actually makes a
couple opening mistakes here
and could end up in a slightly worse
position
so let's take a look at it we see g3
knight f6 bishop g2
d5 and now finally after castles
we see white not yet committing to the
c4 move
but just playing all the king side
developing moves
and then after bishop b7 we do see c4
arriving
at this main english tavia that i have
sort of been
talking about see castles by black then
again
white can transpose to the catalan with
d4 but instead goes with b3
we see c5 and then again white can
transpose
into some slightly more boring lines
with c takes d5 when black can take back
either way
but more popular is bishop b2
uh or sorry in this case white plays e3
immediately
not a significant difference we see
knight c6 and then bishop b2
and d4 arriving at our main position
uh we have e takes d4 c takes d4 rookie
one again
this is just the more accurate move
order i think it's fair to say that d3
is
pretty seriously just a mistake note if
white does play d3
black should can and should play the
immediate e5
and meet rookie one with knight d7 uh if
black can get these pawns
as far forward as possible early on then
then you should do it so rookie one the
better move order for white
is what emilio plays we still stick with
this 98 variation
and here we are going to see my
suggested improvement for white of
knight e5
trading off these pieces immediately
uh the game continues
what happens with d takes c4 for black
uh i think
it depends on the moment and the move
order but d take c4 is a playable line
for black as well it's just a totally
different type
type of opening but okay we see 95 and
black
should trade we get rook take c5 and now
the downside again for white is black is
able to play f65
sort of with tempo uh compared to the
previous position
now keeping in mind with last game
and the sort of general uh direction
i've been giving
about what both sides should be doing
who can come up with some interesting
ideas
for white in this position remember last
game
we saw white take a slower approach
trying to utilize this bishop on b2
and i kept saying if white doesn't get
something immediate
then white can often be worse so what's
immediate here for white what can white
try to play
and yeah you guys are exactly right uh
it's the move
f4 uh white should be breaking down
these pawns as quickly as possible
looking for immediate openings in the
position immediate complications
making use of that extra tempo because
if you don't make use of that extra
tempo now
one more time then you're just playing a
bedoni and nobody wants to be playing a
bidoni with the white pieces
so f4 i do think this is actually the
the best line
uh for white and this is what we
actually saw
david howell play against fabiano
caruana in the 2013
london chess classic and now fabi does
go on to win that game with the black
pieces
uh but i haven't included it here
because it went really well
for david howe i i will mention in the
direction that that path
that that game shows and when we'll
deviate from it but uh i wanted to
mention
i think this is probably the best line
for white this immediate f4 and it's not
very very common
by players with the white pieces much
more common is to play something like
bishop a3
again going for those slower benoni type
games that we've seen before
and with two pieces off the board
meaning these knights in these bishops
it turns out that black probably doesn't
have a
very big advantage at all but in the
games i was looking at
it does tend to feel like white is the
one trying to equalize trying to make
something happen to improve the position
whereas black sword just has a
comfortable edge in space
so don't really want to go over these
bishop a3 lines because they're a little
bit more
boring a little bit slower and black's
plans are very similar to the first game
we looked at
but f4 i think is quite tempting for
white
and should very much be looked at
thoroughly
so the direction that fabi took is to
actually capture on f4
and then uh here the the database games
actually take another split
about half the people play the move
queen f3 here uh applying some pressure
on this diagonal uh and the other half
play
uh david howell's move of g takes f4 and
g takes f4 i do think
is correct if you play queen f3 you know
black can and should probably just play
f takes g and b up uh upon momentarily
uh so g takes f uh played
in the game and i think this is uh well
sorry not our game played in fabiano's
game
and i think this is correct by david
howell and then fabi chose to play this
move bishop c5
and actually ended up being a little bit
worse after queen f3
i should mention the idea of queen f3
isn't just to apply pressure down this
diagonal
after fabi's move of verkb8 uh while
david howe played bishop a3 first
but the idea is to go queen d5 and sort
of isolate this pawn on d4
from from friendly forces but david hall
goes bishop a3 first
and just to show you a few more moves
queen d5 check was inserted here
takes king h8 93
and then fabi had a tough time uh
keeping this pawn together and i think
actually ended up going down upon
in this game again bobby did go on to
win but that's
mostly due to him being fabiana
carowanna and not
to his opening choices so that's what we
want to avoid that's what we want to
avoid this kind of stuff
and so i would suggest an improvement
for fabi here
is to actually just play the move knight
c7 or king
h8 i think both of these moves are
better than bishop c5 because we saw
bishop c5 turned out to be a little bit
of a wasted tempo
as black ends up capturing on a3 anyways
knight c7
takes immediate control over the d5
square and prevents this queen f3 idea
and king h8 similarly is stepping out of
queen d5 with check
and sort of lessening that threat
so just a brief aside on the highest
level game that's made it this far
uh it did go well for white so i thought
it was worth worth addressing
what should have been done there in our
game though we are taking a look at the
move
of bishop to d6 this is what this random
2300 chose to play against emilio
cordova and i think it's quite an
interesting option
uh compared to taking on f4
so what's what's the point of bishop d6
well the point is
we are saying no to weakening our d4
pawn and i think this move is actually
more in line
with the general philosophy of the
opening for black
than fabi's move of e takes f4 what do i
mean by that
well our point is to say white has a bad
benoni because this bishop is stuck
on b2 if we play e takes f4
we've weakened this pawn and white is
well on their way
towards making this bishop useful
by attacking on d4 so with bishop d6
we're saying your bishop is still bad it
will have to stay here on b2
and do nothing now perhaps emilio should
have chosen the move
bishop a3 as in the game between david
hal and fabiano
but here black has a couple different
options a couple different paths to
continue
uh perhaps the best of which is to just
go with rook b8
and continue playing slowly white is
eventually going to capture on e5
see f takes e5 and white can put some
immediate pressure onto e5
but black can somehow albeit a little
bit loosely
keep everything together and keep this
central space advantage
but this is the type of immediate
threats that white is looking for white
needs to be making threats early on in
this
opening or else they could run into
danger
so that's not what we see in the game
though instead we see emilia play the
move queen f3 which i think is
is still fine similar ideas as to
fabiano's game now of course black
should not be taking
on the f4 on the f4 pawn because we
are in fact just hanging our d4 pawn for
it instead we see knight c7 which is
very
very sensible taking control of the d5
square
by xiao and then emilio plays the move
f5 so i wanted to ask you guys in the
chat
what you think about this move of f5
what do you think about this one
that random 2300 is a 12 year old fm i
did not
do any googling on lyran zhao before the
class so i will take your word for it
that's very impressive no wonder
uh this this was such a well-played game
maybe liran zhao is a name everybody
will know in the future
yeah and and so the chat is gaining up
on poor emilio cordova
and calling this a very very bad move uh
i tend to agree
uh again uh it all comes down to this
philosophy
where white needs to make something
happen rather quickly right white needs
to make something happen open things up
make use of the extra tempo early on or
else black is going to have a favorable
position
favorable position thanks to the central
pawn duo
and having this pawn move from f2 to f5
hasn't really done enough
to lessen this advantage of the central
pawn duo and now
black doesn't really have any immediate
urgent problems
as we would see if there was still this
dark squared pressure
so what would have been better for
emilio is again i think going with this
move
bishop a3 uh and playing things just a
little bit more
immediately also possible is just
keeping the tension with something like
d3
and sort of you know biting biting your
time here just keeping the tension
you definitely don't want to release the
pressure on these dark squares
because that's the moment when black can
sort of breathe cy relief
and have a better position so f5 played
in the game
and now zhao continues out with the move
a5
which perhaps isn't strictly necessary
right away
uh but it does uh play a nice
preventative role of controlling the b4
square
i just think perhaps this tempo could
have been better spent with developing
moves like
rook b8 or bishop d7 or rook b8 followed
by bishop d7
but a5 is is perfectly fine as well a4
by emilio is a really interesting move
uh
the idea here for emilio is that
he wants to make use of the king's side
space by completely locking down
the queen's side and it actually works
for him in this game
but i think it's because uh black is
perhaps as i've now been informed
a 12 year old fm and when you're a grand
master playing against a 12 year old fm
sometimes you are better at chest than
them and i think that was just the case
here
uh so black i do think is much much
better in this position
thanks to the extra central space as i
keep saying but we'll see the tide
slowly start to turn in this game as
emilio just outplays his opponent
rook b8 is played by black and i quite
like this move just
freeing up this bishop by defending the
b pawn
we see d3 now by cordova bishop b4
is an interesting if perhaps a little
bit unnecessary move
by zhao we see rook f1 just stepping off
of the e file
now bishop d7 again i think black is
playing fine so far
queen d1 bishop c6 knight d2
and then uh here we see i think xiao
sort of losing the thread of the
position
i think simplest would be to go
something like knight a6 c5 and just
keep up some really dominant pressure on
the queen side
you can contin you can continue with
something like queen b6
introduce some threats of breaking
through with e4 as we saw in ivan
chuck's game
and threats of just attacking these
weaknesses on the queen side
instead of that we see zhao sort of
going on a trade fest
which i think sort of hands the
advantage back over to cordova
and this happens with the move bishop c3
and the idea of this
is that there is a nice little little
idea here
that this knight really doesn't have any
good squares because queen d4
check and knight a6 or bishop takes
and this pawn is actually going to be
quite quite strong
in the position um so bishop takes c3
shouldn't be played but of course
captures are not forced in chess so
cordova simply plays rook b1 defending
the piece
and now we see our bishop our strong
bishop on b4 traded for the passive
bishop on b2
seemingly for for no reason so i think
this is sort of the beginning
of letting the advantage slip for black
and and now we see 96
94 queen e7 which is fine g4
and we see another trade by black this
time it makes a bit more sense to leave
yourself with a good knight
against this bishop but then the the
sort of
final move where black has the
advantages here you have to play the
move knight c5 this is just the best
square for the knight attacking all of
the weaknesses
uh instead knight b4 was played and now
white is is just firmly in control
without any of these minor pieces left
on the queen side to attack these
weaknesses
the queen side is effectively locked
down and now we see emilio simply
pushing on the king's side
and checkmating black and that's what
happens in the game i won't spend too
much time because it's quite sad
uh to see but we do see
a check a check and a check and resigns
by uh learning zhao uh king e8 for
example
means bishop g6 and the the queen is
dead
so it all sort of turned very very
quickly there for black but i think it's
all down to these strange trading moves
that just were simply unnecessary
by black better to apply some pressure
bring more pieces into the position
and introduce some threats of pushing
with e4 as we saw in evonchook's games
okay so
any questions on this game here and
especially
this brief aside i i had about fabiana
caruana's game and why i don't actually
like this move e takes f4 too much why i
actually prefer this random 2300s move
to two fobbies any questions
so why not bishop d7 bishop c6 so yeah
it did happen in the game
the main reason it wasn't happening
earlier is because this pawn
was under a little bit of pressure and
so it had to be sort of prefaced with
rook b8
in some cases
how does d3 keep the tension okay so
with
f5 uh we are releasing the tension the
tension between
the f4 pawn and the e5 pawn so d3 keeps
the tension
by just leaving these pawns in contact
as opposed to f5 now any other
reasonable move would also keep the
tension like knight a3 is fine
but d3 i think is just the most normal
looking of the moves that just keeps
these pawns in contact
our pawn chain's a staple of the the
bononi i think pawn chains are a staple
of chess
but um yeah i guess you could say
bononis
uh tend to have longer pawn chains than
than most
okay i think i'm gonna call this game
here
as i do have one more game i want to
show you guys and
now i've introduced uh not too many
specific lines but a lot of general
ideas about the opening
so i want to sort of put you guys to the
test here i myself have played a game
with the black pieces in this variation
against one feed a master by the name of
josh kolas
uh and i want to see if you guys can
uh sort of answer some questions about
how the opening is going for either
player
so let's take a look uh i of course have
the black pieces and josh
has the white pieces here and we start
very normally with knight f3 knight of
six
c4 and we get into this position that i
keep talking about
where black goes for this nice little
setup that we see in so many openings in
d4
in one d4 i mean we get bishop g2 bishop
b7
b3 uh in before castles but it doesn't
change much we still see castles by
black castles by white
now c5 bishop b2 knight c6 e3
and d4 and we have arrived at our main
position
uh e takes d4 played in the game we see
c takes d4
by me uh and now d3 by josh so again
i do think this is in fact just a less
accurate move order
for white white should put this pressure
on the e5
square so that black cannot freely play
the move e5
as i do in this game now we see rookie 1
by white
knight d7 a3 by white and of course
the automatic move a5 just just like in
the benoni
whenever you see a six plate in the
binoni a4 is an automatic response for
white almost always
and here whenever you see a3 it makes a
lot of sense to play the move a5
now we see the move knight bd2 and i
want to pause here
and ask you guys to evaluate uh how
these past few moves have gone
for either side who should be happy
about
what has happened in this opening who
should be happy here
who should be happy elvis feels that
black is better
jamaica feels that black is better
apollo thinks white should be happy
i should be happy white went into a
benoni so there is a little bit of
discord in the chat here so i am going
to say
that black should be very very happy
about the way these past few moves have
gone
in this opening and the reason for that
is a few different things
number one white has not managed to make
any immediate threats
what does this mean well this means that
we are in fact
just sort of in a normal benoni so it's
as if i got to play with the white
pieces and i got to play
you know the white side of the benoni
which is great because i actually
started with the black pieces
aside from that white has already
severely limited
his options somewhat with the past few
choices that he made
this move a3 looks very very natural to
continue out with the idea of b4
but when you play this move you really
do deprive yourself of this extra piece
of knight a3 to c2 that could
potentially support
this b4 push and even more so
you lock this bishop in on this bad
square of b2
for example bishop a3 is a very popular
move in this position
and bishop a3 ideas would still exist
after something like knight 3 to c2 when
white always has this idea
in reserve white has not yet committed
to this move of a3
and the same idea exists in the benoni
where it can sometimes be a mistake
to play the move a6 too quickly when
black is the side with with less space
in the normal benoni i should say
so with a3 in particular i think this is
a a pretty bad misstep
by josh that does give black some
serious advantage
in the opening uh after a5 stopping b4
i should mention by the way there is
another yvonne chick game here
from 1986 but i didn't actually take a
look at that when i was prepping so
we'll stick with my game
uh so a3 a5 played in the game we see
knight beat e2
and then i actually play the the move
king h8 and
that is sort of indicative of how the
opening has gone for white if black has
time to play moves like king h8
simple solidifying moves like this then
it's pretty clear
that black should be happy about how
this opening is gone i'm gonna say one
more time
white is the one who has to sort of rush
to make something happen
in this opening or else white is just
playing a bedoni and the benoni
is not that good not that good with the
white pieces
not even that good with the black pieces
but uh you know
nobody should be choosing to play the
benoni with white
if you don't get something immediately
for it okay
so king h8 and black is better
now queen e2 is played in the game by
josh and
this should be telling you uh what
white's idea sort of is
now this bishop is hemmed in on b2 white
really has to rush to make it useful
by pressuring this pawn on d4 otherwise
this is just a bad bishop sitting on b2
uh and then because i am not perfect at
chess
uh i do hand the game back to
josh and and then we have uh sort of
equality again
so the mistake i make is not really
immediately obvious or
at least obviously it wasn't to me i
play the move
bishop d6 and i was quite happy with
this move when i played it
because now there's no pressure down the
e file because this is not a pin
there's nothing to pin and i'm leaving
this bishop stuck
here on b2 but there is a tactical
reason why this move
does allow white back into the game
somewhat so a better move
would have been the simple rookie 8 and
then black again
is going to be significantly better you
just nullify this pressure down the
down the e file and like i keep saying
this bishop is just going to be awful
awful awful on b2
it has no prospect of trading itself off
because white has committed to the move
of a3
and black has a powerful central pawn
duo
nothing to be said about here for black
but with the move bishop d6
josh does find the very nice way to get
back into the game
and that's with the move knight e4
forcing this bishop to make another
decision
i didn't really feel like repeating
moves because i thought i should be
better
so i played bishop c7 but this does
allow a tactical idea for white
to to start gaining some counter play
and this is with the move b4
this is the idea that i missed in the
game i foolishly assumed
that this square was attacked twice and
defended once
but you know it as always it's a little
bit more complicated
than that so who sees why b4 works
who sees it who sees why b4 works
ah and where was this game played
is an excellent question it was played
in 2019 at the st louis chess
club but what tournament was it i wonder
i wonder i don't remember i don't
remember what game it was
sadly
alright so why does b4 work i think the
chat might be having some technical
difficulties
so we will continue the rook is hanging
that doesn't have
anything to do with it it has to do with
this rook which is not hanging it's
defended but it can
be susceptible to this terrible bishop
that i sort of forgot about
sitting here on b2 after a takes b4 it
takes b4
or takes a1 takes a1 knight takes b4
there is the awkward
bishop a3 when uh amazingly
i have no way to defend my knight and
break out of this pen
bishop a5 for example means rook b1 and
i am forced to lose in exchange
so of course i didn't do this
but this is the idea that i missed that
being said
white has done enough wrong in the
opening that black still
shouldn't really be worse and that was
the case in the game so
white is breaking through with b4 it's
very very scary i'm very afraid
and white does have immediate threats in
the position once again
which is why black is no longer really
better
so what are those threats that white is
making well
let's say we play a normal move like f6
we're going to get slammed with the move
b5
now knight e7 now a4 and all of a sudden
this once for lauren bishop
is going to spring to life on a3 and our
once happy bishop
is now sort of trapped on the c7 square
not very fun at all
so black needs to be doing uh
something active here needs to be
playing a little bit more quickly which
is why the move f5
is correct now 90 g5 is played in the
game
and i continue with queen to f6 uh sort
of importantly
giving this knight the d8 square to
counter this knight on g5
and reroute it back into the game uh we
do see b5 in the game
knight d8 now h4 is white's idea
and white does sort of go on the
offensive over here on the king's side
i play h6 to force this knight away and
king up to h7
sort of anticipating that a knight is
going to land on g6
white still plays h5 now i see 96
improving my knight and josh does go for
this knight h4 idea
and here once again we do just have a
quality
now why is this equality when i was
claiming that yvonne chuck's position
was much better it seems that the
positions are very very similar we have
the same structure in the center with
f5 e5 and d4 but a key difference
is that white has gained all this space
on the queen side
white now once again is able to improve
this bishop potentially with a4 in
bishop a3
and also very importantly white has
introduced threats
uh on the queen's side to on the king's
side to
the position so white has a lot more
going for him here
than they did in ivan shook's game
so important to notice these key
differences but that being said black is
still
doing a-okay here in this position it
was actually important to play the move
rook d8
with the idea of clearing away this f8
square for the knight to challenge this
incoming knight on g6
instead i was a trade gamer making
similar mistakes to that 12 year old
fm where i was like i just want to trade
pieces so i played
knight g5 and it does turn out that this
is going to be slightly worse
for black after takes takes and knight
g6
when now this knight is sort of a
permanent fixture because
awkwardly i'm unable to play the move uh
knight f8 to kick it away
because then the pawn on e5 is going to
hang so
this makes stuff a little bit a little
bit trickier notably also rook e8
is now hanging the pawn on d4 and
black's position is
is actually quite bad so this was missed
by josh though josh instead
opted for this knight takes f5 tactic
which i did
in fact see coming uh i of course cannot
capture due to bishop e4 but
knight c5 is going to be good enough now
when this knight is actually simply
trapped on the f5 square and i have
prevented
the idea of bishop e4 winning my queen
the game continues though with g4 we see
takes
takes and then in the ensuing
complications it all trends towards
equality
as chess often does this stuff is a
little bit beyond the scope of the
opening
so i'm sort of just fast forwarding here
we get this little tactical line where
white takes my rook but i take his rook
we get this inner meso rook takes e1
then i play the very bad move rook b8
trying to defend my pawn don't know why
i thought that was important
uh bishop b4 queen f4 played in the game
c5 b6 to lock things up we get take and
take
and now thanks to this pressure down the
f file black is able
to uh hold the game to a draw
i have my past pawn white has their past
pawn white has a little bit more
pressure on my center
but white's king is actually a bit less
safe than blacks here
and so we do end up getting a draw
g4 is an important break by the way to
loosen up this
king's position further we see
now white is the one having to trade off
queens because we had all this pressure
around the king
and despite being down a pawn here black
is perfectly fine
because of this powerful pawn on d2
and we get a repetition and a draw it
was the st
louis district championship where this
was played ben simon
doing the research live on air uh
okay so questions on this final game
uh that i wanted to show you guys i
think this is
uh you know the first two games were
sort of uh
instructive and this this is supposed to
be you know what actually happens in the
game right
we get mistakes by both sides we see
black should be better
but then white finds a way back into the
game via tactical means
and this is what you can sort of expect
to see from an actual game
in this variation so questions on this
one
questions on this one
why not g5 to kick the white knight
let's
look at it let's look at it here
um ah that would be due
to on passant
on passant very terrifying rule that
would be bad
what makes bishop a3 good in these
positions so
generally the difference from the norm
here is that i did this
really strange maneuver of bishop d6 to
c7
this was with the idea of supporting
like e4 f4 pushes
but the huge downside is that it really
does leave this diagonal just
wide open for white to take which is why
a4 bishop a3
is sort of keeping weight in the game in
a lot of positions here so
uh generally it's only a strong it's
only strong enough to trade off bishops
but because i've done this slightly
strange maneuver
it would just be sort of an unopposed
bishop on the strong diagonal
[Music]
okay well i think that is going to do it
for us here tonight then
this has been my chess openings
explained show
on the reverse benoni and a lot of the
intricacies that go into it
uh what white has to be doing early on
is fight
for tactical advantages fight to open
the position fight for
immediate advantages and black on the
other hand
is just aiming to steer the game towards
a slightly slower
more normal benoni where black of course
is playing
as the site with extra space always a
fun time
hopefully you enjoyed those three
examples that i ended up showing you
from three different games i think there
was a lot to go over here
so thank you all for sticking it out
with me hopefully you found this useful
if you're watching live please head on
over to the twitch channel where we're
going to continue the fun
with an episode of tactics time if
you're watching the youtube version or
if you've just
had enough chess for the night i want to
thank you very much for watching
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you
next time
that's it
[Music]
you